96 deep well plates are for sample  retrieval mixing and storage we have  both one mil and two mil Round Top and  round bottom plate depending on the size  of the solution and your application  these also come in square tops they are  made of the solvent resistant  polypropylene material and have an  alphanumeric indexing molded in on an a  dash H and 1-12 axes for tracking your  samples we also offer the 96 well played  conical ceiling Mat made of silicone to  help protect your samples and keep them  in one place to prevent contamination  conversely you can also use the aluminum  foil as a cost-effective way to seal  your plates